won't we cure it what identity are we
going to introduce okay so you can um
yeah suppose you can say that's five on
X hat side of X minus one
I think we're confident that you can
mentally do that all you really need is
that that pair of batteries right so now
what I definitely will have introduced
on the basis of that yep okay
now when you go ahead and you put this
together into one fraction you're
getting this and I'm just going to put
that back into its own factorized form
and then of course you do the same
comparison of coefficients what did you
get for a yeah so therefore what I have
done is taken something which began if I
were to say hey I can integrate this I
don't know I'm the dreamer that like and
actually if I wanted this to be an
doesn't even have any X's up there at
least over here I was like kind in the
ballpark but he you're really up depict
about power but here I can now say all
right I will write the original by the
way please make sure that you actually
say this line when they said decompose
into as partial fractions don't just
start with a and B you're gonna take
anything back to where they belong so
there's a that's a minus
well yeah it actually it's it's it's at
that point it does not really matter
whether you say they're congruent and
equal it always equal identical or
whether you say the equal because
they're they're both good language codes
okay now I'm just going to pause for
America so I got a question
I didn't want to cloud your your process
through this question too much by
showing you model methods at the
beginning but I will just pause since it
was raised and show you this anyway if
you have a look at this so the original
question we did to demonstrate this
principle at this point we then launched
into this right I'm sorry not that point
I have simplified it so I had all the X
terms in other constant terms and then I
did my comparison
but it's not the only way you can work
out what a and B are if you have a look
at this knowing that the left hand side
and right hand side are all equal and
illegal right simply like choosing an
appropriate value of x you can make a
and B sort of jump out at you okay
for example you could let X equal 1 now
if I let X equal 1 see what happens to
this thing this guy just vanishes right
because he becomes 0 this is something
like what we were doing with factor
theorem remainder theorem before if this
vanishes all you get left with over here
is 6 plus 2 which is equal to a times 4
and you get the same that's able to so
you get the same now then of course you
can do the same thing now this is kind
of okay I think it's alright you get the
right answer
obviously and you get a tea or an exam
the reason why I'm a little bit if you
matter and it's certainly not the first
way that I showed you is that there's
just a teeny teeny little problem with
saying this has anyone noticed
you you really shouldn't all right on
this particular question that exact
value in fact the precise values you
need to make this work the reason why
they work is because they make one of
your denominator zero okay now as you've
noticed that ends up being because I'm
just ending up comparing the numerators
right I'm just trying to solve for n V
which is nothing to do with the
denominator so therefore I'm kind of
treating it as a secondary question now
in the same way that solving these some
seriously is a secondary question at the
same time I just did a little bit
uncomfortable with saying something that
I know is completely at odds with the
way the question began I think it's not
the greatest patent to set yourself up
into because that's how students make
errors by forgetting all this domain
restriction this like that's a it's one
of those classic errors that any two
unit or extension one or extensive two
student can make so it'll get you the
right answer fairly quickly as well
maybe you want to use that as a
confirmation for how you went through
and the numbers that you ended up with
especially when you're not having a few
more of them but just just be cautious
with it I'm also you can see the
usefulness of this method starts to
reduce like here is that oh cool it just
made the B vanish right well when you
don't have two partial fractions but
when you're going to end up with not two
but three you're gonna have an a term a
B term and then there's a C term and
there's no one number you can put in
there they get rid off two of the UM two
of the constants right you always end up
with two of them left over and so you
end up back in this situation do you see
what I mean so I'll keep that be back
sleep
the vast majority will end up with a
pair of partial fractions so you know
it's not bad right
just like factorizing this is quite
useful even though you can't factorize
everything sometimes you need to cook
that for middle but um I would use this
as my main life